mike zimmer coach of the vikings pulled
off a victory on sunday
paul allen stealing mike zimmer's
headphones for our segment today are
those zimmer's headphones
um i i can neither confirm nor deny but
uh my friend teddy says hello to you
teddy
say hello hey teddy what's up teddy hi
teddy and uh
look he's got this and by the way the
numbers on the back here michael
uh before we beat houston was like what
i felt our final uh
win total was going to be this year and
i think teddy would love mason
okay teddy i like the tri-colored teddy
uh what are you doing wearing an nfl
logo hat you're like rob
lowe with the toque instead of the cap
you don't want to see
you don't want to see the hair i didn't
have time with the breeders cup friday
and saturday i didn't have time to uh
to get my hair done so here i am so what
were you thinking on sunday when the
vikings were going through
literally the swiss cheese of the green
bay packers defense now it was back and
forth in the first half but they pulled
away in the second half it basically was
a tennis match
the vikings broke serve once and that
was that what were your impressions
well um we've always known green bay's
kryptonite is a
physical running game c next level
shanny two times last year
uh dalvin got him for 75 last year it's
just the quarterback couldn't close on
it king picked him off
so that's the kryptonite and uh dalvin
broke their spirit and
and i think that was really evident
michael when um there was an extra point
that the long snapper snapped really
high and culplit
got it and put it down and barely banged
it through but the majority of the
packers had their hands on their hips
and
you know if they had run in there to try
to block that they would have blocked it
but they uh
they had their spirit broken you know
it's funny aaron rodgers said after the
game that he noticed a lack of energy
and i know you're not at the games in
person but did you
sense beyond that extra point did you
sense something different about the
packers on sunday
i've just i've just seen it before
because i like watching green bay
packers football a lot i'm a fan of
aaron rodgers and aaron jones
and they're the number one team to beat
every year in the division so i've just
seen it with certain teams who do it a
certain way
and and they stick with it and i mean
dalvin's situation was an aberration
because he just
he was unstoppable specifically with
that 50-yard screen
you know darnell savage is a fantastic
second year safety michael
but he's been on the wrong side of just
getting shaken out of his cleats by
dalvin
uh the last two games of lambo so that's
what dalvin does
and uh it never really was just a a
pounded ahead running game i mean
it was big run after big run quarterback
only had to throw 14
times for my taste his best game of the
season because he hit on all the right
third downs and
now you uh now you play the kitties beat
the packers
gave the seahawks everything they could
handle gave the titans everything they
could handle
and when you look at the upcoming
schedule starting with the lions coming
to town this weekend and and we're
supposed to go one game at a time
because that's what
they all do but we're allowed to peak
ahead there's a stretch here where you
know the monday night game in chicago is
never a gimme that always turns out
poorly for the vikings it seems like but
the bears aren't as good as they were
earlier this year
i feel like if they can get past this
lions game
maybe they can start to put a little
something together and before you know
it maybe start
getting getting to a point where 500 is
attainable
i'm with you um i'm not big dwell guy
you know and certainly hopefully the
players and coaches aren't either
specifically out of the buy
off the upset of lambo man the uh the
tennessee and seattle games two good
teams it's just a shame they didn't get
those games because
specifically with some of the defensive
players that you know zimmer's rolling
out they're doing the best he can
um but now moving forward that this and
i'm not going one game at a time on to
cincinnati michael
but it's consistency has been a problem
with this team and and you've said it on
my show
and and said it um and said it with
chris in the morning you you don't
do to seattle what you did and then
do with atlanta what you did it just
can't happen
you know and the quarterback has to be
better and he only threw 14 last time
and
he's gonna throw more of this game uh
jefferson should have a
nice nice game this weekend but they
have to be consistent and come
through one thing kyle rudolph told me
last friday on this program the vikings
have an issue
not just recovering from a big loss
that leaves them feeling deflated they
have an issue with recovering from a big
win
should there be concern of a letdown
after this upset of the packers
that's a great question because i mean
here we are wednesday practice is done
i know who was out there i know what
their vibe is i don't know who the
coroners are going to be this weekend
outside of jeff gladney
and you got the temple rookie harrison
hand i mean at the end of the game you
had those two rookies trying to slow an
hof quarterback
and devonte adams with safety joshua
josh mitchell a rookie playing for the
first time all season
anthony harris goes down to nickel so if
you got a full week to do something like
that i guess it could be better
and green bay is better than detroit but
there's that component of it
now you're coming home to the empty
stadium super quiet
you know and and when you want the skull
channel let's get going here from two
and five just like florio says
beat this team no fans at soldier field
go beat that team
then you got dallas carolina and
jacksonville whatever order go beat them
it's it's they need to motivate
themselves
better than they did against atlanta and
better than they've done most of the
season honestly
i feel like i never understand the
specific deadlines that apply to the
covet 19 reserve list and the various
ways you can land on it but matthew
stafford now on the covet 19 reserve
lift that doesn't bode well
for him playing this weekend and without
stafford
i don't know three and five looking
pretty good yeah we went through it last
week with cam
dantzler and i'm not going to guess on
the exact days for matthew
but like danceler i guess he he was next
he was was
by somebody who got bit or something
like that so now all of a sudden you're
in protocol
and then now the testing monday so
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday which means his testing began
tuesday into wednesday with the contact
racing so he had to come up good
on sunday which he did that's why he was
able to play then he got hurt
so i'm assuming stafford needs to go not
detected in bio reference terms uh
wednesday thursday friday saturday
sunday then he's in i bet she plays
how often they test you uh twice a week
when uh when the titans rolled in here
uh with some
positive players and uh played the team
then then it got a little herky-jerky
here and everywhere
um that was two times a week uh up to
three with point of contact
each time so then you gotta wait in the
parking lot you know make sure that you
don't come up detected
um but basically once or twice a week to
get into the facility
three days a week in my little
quarantine vikings entertainment network
area
i haven't been to the locker room i
haven't been out to practice i haven't
been to zimmer's office
it's 20 20 man i'm accepting what's it
like calling a game in an empty stadium
i don't like it um i really don't i like
calling the road games off tv a lot
better now granted we haven't won a game
at home
and uh the houston seattle and green bay
games are super exciting
they play the star-spangled banner
whether you're in prayer or it's just
uh it's just some type of private
stimulating moment for you
however that's what it is and the
stimulation of the crowd is very
important to me
uh when we um when we unfurl the boom
and do the game as business as usual
that's what it has to be
uh but i like calling the road games off
tv
better than home games with zero
fans well it's got to be a weird season
for everybody paul
and uh you're still the best at what you
do fans are no fans home or away
watching it on tv or there in person we
appreciate some of your time
send me one of those hats send me a set
of those headphones let's see the hair
you we're going to see the hair
i got it for you let's see i love you
because old school is in
school there were like 14 people at
profootballtalk.com when he was rogue
and i came in old school best school
here we go
viewer discretion advised hello oh god
put it back on ella that's pretty good
for being stuck under a hat
but you know what it's not already my
god
my god yeah you are already lying let's
take a break
[Music]
in america when pfpm continues right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports